alexandra rosetti mer depuis 2014 et
candidat pour un second mandat
construction de l'écoquartier
amélioration de la circulation et de
l'espace public parmi ces projets de lui
tiennent à coeur
une salle des fêtes un lieu dédié où les
gens puissent faire c'est leur mariage
leur anniversaire puisque aujourd'hui
voisins a beaucoup de salles de quartier
mais tout est enclavée dans des
résidences qu'on a un projet de maison
plus vie professionnelle de santé dans
le quartier de la grande île et
ça c'est un enjeu important parce qu'on
a la moitié de nos médecins généralistes
qui partent à la retraite
cette maison pluri professionnelle de
santé serait à l'emplacement de l'ancien
leader price avec seize logements à
l'étagé pour présenter ses actions
opération de porte à porte pour
alexandra rosetti par quartier halte à
la bretonnière on vous donne voilà un
petit document sur ce qu'on a fait dans
votre quartier c'est un quartier qui a
quelques commerces également à l'entrée
qu'il convient d'essayer de préserver au
maximum puisque les boulangeries qui a
disparu par exemple alexandra rosetti
est allé à la rencontre des habitants
l'occasion de revenir sur certains
travaux de voirie et de faire connaître
les futurs membres de la nouvelle équipe
que les racines des arbres on m'a dit
que des fois les voitures exemple était
dedans c'est très bien parce qu'on peut
évidemment l'échangé avait directement
et le maire et puis le conseil municipal
madame le maire c'est la première à
passer l'échangé direct et on a le moyen
de dire ce qu'on pense
une réunion publique aura lieu le 2 mars
à 20 heures à la maison des associations
du plan de l'église